[Music]
on ya alright what's up everyone welcome
to simulation we are super excited to be
talking about experimental philosophy
today we are sitting down with Jonathan
Keats thank you for coming on to our
show very happy to be here we really
appreciate it and your background is
freaking awesome we are going to be
exploring all of the experiments
philosophy that you've been doing or as
much of it as we can fit and also what's
the point of it why is it so important
and where are we gonna go in the future
with more experiments of philosophy so
let's ask like what is experiments of
philosophy and how did you get started
in it well I studied philosophy
academically in in college and found
that it was not exactly what I expected
I had some sort of a naive notion that
it was being Socrates going around
asking big questions and engaging
everybody in the in the conversation but
it turned out particularly as I was
studying analytic philosophy which is a
particularly persnickety pursuit that in
fact what was expected was a narrow sub
section of a small segment of a question
that was miniscule that could be worked
on for an entire lifetime and that's
just the nature of specialization in any
academic pursuit so of course this is
the sort of thing that I could talk
about perfectly well with three people
in the same department but not my mother
not anyone out on the street and so it
was ultimately failing to accomplish
what I wanted to achieve which was I'm
motivated by curiosity fundamentally I
basically I just never bothered growing
up I didn't realize that I was supposed
to do so and I finally figured out that
I hadn't and it was much better that way
so I'm curious and interested in trying
to bring others into
back into the sort of state of childhood
where all possibilities are open and
where everything is interesting and
everything can be explored and it may
explore explore experimentally it can be
explored in ways that are indeterminate
so essentially what I did was I I left I
got my degree they here that might as
well at least get that far with it and
then I I escaped and went out into the
world to try to figure out how do I go
about what I thought philosophy is and
what I thought philosophy does or really
more generally what I think philosophy
ought to do and everything that is done
in academia is perfectly legitimate but
at the same time I think is insufficient
in our society particularly given that
our society is necessarily a society in
which people are engaged in questioning
in critically engaging the function of
the society because ultimately
collective self-determination is what
democracy is all about so combine my
selfish childhood interest in pursuing
curiosity with some sort of a rather
grandiose mission to try to bring people
into a state of questioning and of
conversation and critical thinking and
you end up in some weird nebulous world
where I ended up which is the art world
and I ended up there only because it's
probably the only space in society right
now that has moved in the opposite
direction of specialization that you
find throughout academic pursuit so not
only in philosophy but also when you
think about in the sciences for instance
it's necessary to specialize because the
body of knowledge upon which any current
study is built is so vast that you
necessarily can't learn it all in
advance so in order to do the science
you become a specialist art on the other
hand has gone from specialization where
you had a voce
you had a mityay in let's say sculpture
and you learned very specific techniques
to a crisis that happened through Dada
through Marcel Duchamp basically
bringing a urinal and showing it as an
artwork and therefore effectively
proclaiming that art is undefinable and
that the undefined ability of it is its
virtue one interpretation amongst many
one that I happen to like that that then
led to a sort of a crisis an existential
crisis within within the arts that have
allowed for absolutely anything to
happen and so a lot of what has happened
as a result has been a sort of rather
boring in my opinion and somewhat and
somewhat abstruse recapitulation of that
moment of rebellion but it also meant
that I could go into the art world make
use of the mechanisms and I could
undertake what I think of as large-scale
thought experiment so basically what so
recall of a rika lip ulation what is
that a recalculation yeah it's a great
term I have never come across it before
me I think Ron was referring to a word
that you said just a couple moments ago
but that has also slipped in my mind as
well but you were on a very awesome
stream of consciousness right there and
there was I want to I want to will be
right where we you left off but I want
to bring us back sherry you started and
then will come right to where you left
off okay so you brought us into this
world of curiosity the importance of
curiosity for the young child's mind and
we have a there's been so many of these
examples Neil deGrasse Tyson talks about
the one where a child whips out a bunch
of pots and pans from the cabinets and
just starts hitting them with stuff and
then the parent goes stop
Marian can't say stop there you gotta
say play the parents got to sit down
with the kid and start playing with the
kid as well that this sort of curiosity
where the child is running around
through through the grass and through
the plants and of course trying to not
get poison ivy and try
not get harmed her in any way but still
at least be able to explore freely with
their curiosity that is the now like you
were describing retaining that through
adulthood and Pablo Picasso talks about
the importance of retention of childhood
through adulthood and if we can unlock
that inner child innate curiosity within
us through life it changes us forever
for the better and now that's so great
that you were describing how in in
academia and even just now in general we
have such broad volumes of knowledge
across all these different fields that a
majority of what we have to do sometimes
to specialize or to get involved is we
have to go and read those volumes of
knowledge if I want to get into
neuroscience I have to go and read about
I should try and apply the Pareto
principle and find the 20% of the most
important neuroscience knowledge that's
gonna give me 80% of the knowledge that
I need in neuroscience and then spend as
much time there and then go and figure
out what I want to do in neuroscience
and so what you know what you were able
to describe here now is that with
experimental philosophy you're taking
the what would is normally known as just
going and and specializing and just kind
of following a path that so many people
follow and just flipping it on its head
and this is kind of what we've been
doing in the past but we haven't been
doing it to the extent that you have
across different disciplines as well and
I like how you set an art that we were
just at MoMA a couple months ago and I
took a photo of those you know there's
like a red triangle and like a green
square and like a white circle and the
yellow whatever
Pentagon or whatever and they're on the
walls and I took a photo of that I'm
talking about this all of it
you would know how much better you would
know much better what I'm talking about
you're so much more fluent in this and I
am but I took a photo of that and I
posted it to social media and I just
said like what does this modern art mean
to you mm-hmm
I was just inquiring about what people
thought about it but you were describing
how art has went through this kind of
phase where art can just be whatever now
the urinal
the wall the green square you know
whatever it wants to be
but there's something deeper there's a
deeper seed in in Picasso's art and in
Asher's art there's these deeper seeds
of something that is screaming towards
the world of profundity and I want to
uncover what funda T some what does that
work something that's perfectly gonna
reach the less educated people this is
important so now that's profound about
something that's very profound something
that basically is extremely interesting
or intriguing so so now maybe we come to
this point where you just were at the or
do you have any you haven't want to
comment on the way let me then kind of
backtrack a little bit to I think a
really important point that you brought
up about parents not only losing their
own sense of play but also trying to
discourage children from doing so and so
I think that we are in an even worse
situation than maybe I was suggesting at
the outset in terms of the fact that we
just don't allow time for play we don't
think that it's legitimate for ourselves
when we grow up and then we go about
trying to professionalize childhood and
that's just really catastrophic so
absolutely worth emphasizing that point
I would say to begin with and then to
say that in terms of the the art world I
think that there is a reaction to much
modern and contemporary art that is
adverse to that work that is negative
because often the work is intentionally
made opaque or inaccessible and I just
want to emphasize that that's not what
interests me in terms of what I do I'm
very interested in that work in its own
right and it's legitimate it has its own
reason but when I say that I've entered
the art world I've only done so in some
sort of a completely opportunist
when I'm asked what I do for a living I
sometimes say experimental philosopher
but then I say real really I'm a
dilettante really what I'm what's a
dilettante a dilettante is somebody who
so it's generally an insult and at least
in our society and as though an insult
in an insult an insult so calling
somebody a dilettante in cell as an
involuntary celibate no no insult insult
a an SN ult yes as in I spit in your
face Oh so dilettantism woo tiny brain
wiper of other people's bottoms so I
fart in your general direction
dilettantism like a charlatan yes a
dilettante a charlatan also the word
amateur gets used in this way now in a
way that is meant as an insult I
actually take all of these as a
compliment because to me these are the
keys to generalism and to the ability to
as a generalist what it put things
together in unconventional and
unexpected ways in ways that they
otherwise might not be and to illuminate
them from other perspectives as a result
so really I think that I use the art
world
opportunistically sometimes as a space
in which I can get away with doing
whatever I want it's kind of black
sheepy a little bit of Copernicus see
we're trying to find this 1% at point
zero zero one percent that nobody's
exploring and why is it so fascinating
how can you make that more interesting
for other people well I think the art
world is maybe more and we're in a
studio here there's a green screen right
over there so well it's the green piece
of cloth I guess if it serves a purpose
treatment the art world is almost
essentially for me a green screen it's
basically it's a it's a space that is
neutral that allows me to to do what I
want and what I want to do is to
undertake what I call thought
experiments and so that is essentially
more than anything else what I have
smuggled out of academic philosophy so I
went into academic philosophy thinking
okay this is all about asking big
questions provoked
those conversations that when you hear
vaguely about Socrates that was a sort
of thing that he was up to
so what academic philosophy taught me
was amongst other things a mode of
argumentation the mode of argumentation
is essentially that you lead your
opponent along through a set of stages
in a scenario that ultimately your
opponent is agreeing to until it reaches
a crisis point as a state of absurdity
and therefore your opponent is caught up
in that and has to surrender well this
is dependent on a number of things first
of all trickery but I'm not particularly
fond I've been secondly of having a
point making an argument where you
effectively are attempting to persuade
somebody and so I never had a point I
was never interested in a point the
other strand as far as my background is
concerned that I think is significant is
I come out of a I'm interested in in Tom
Munich practice of questioning of what's
tell muted so the Talmud was and remains
a central book in Judaism a central body
of law in Judaism but the practice is
one in which you are constantly in a
process of questioning it's also
sometimes we love questions equivalent
to a dialectic to the Chilean value I'm
just trying to say that I love the JCC
absolutely and there should be more of
this sort of questioning in every
possible way and for me the thought
experiment actually can be a mechanism
for doing that as opposed to what it
gets used for in academic philosophy
that is to say instead of using it
rhetorically what if I were to take it
literally and I take most things
literally as a starting point in order
to be able to then examine all the
assumptions that go into this more
sophisticated way in which we we use
ideas we use mechanisms we operate
within our society so I want to get
underneath this
Society inside the society every way
that I possibly can and that can be
experimentally so what I do is instead
of house just envisioning right now me
having a like some sort of a toy here
that I could just pull a string and it
shoot a bunch of like confetti out and
then I would you know throw a beach ball
out into the audience and then do you
know this is an experiment and then just
have watch the audience go whoa and then
you would continue your point and they'd
be hitting the beach ball or something
so these different ways to rather than
just sitting here and talking and let's
do something crazy and fun and cool with
it as well
yes let's see what happens so what if is
the fundamental question that I'm asking
in whatever it is that I do there are
other questions as well but what if so I
can set up an alternative world that is
in fact absurd perhaps in some way and I
can instead of using that as an argument
for saying well okay I led you on you
believe that you're dumb and I'm right
instead I can say let's enter into this
alternate reality and use it as a
vantage to look upon our own world and
of course this is something that you
find in literature throughout history
this is what fable does what folklore
does and right in the present to in a
for more contemporary viewers listeners
and readers what science fiction does
but I want to do it in an experiential
and open-ended way so that is to say
that I set up a world that we can enter
into collectively and we can experience
that we can use that as a way in which
to be able then to reflect on our own
world so to give you an example and I
wanted I want but it so I'm going to do
something so bad right yes they could
get the example you were you were
describing the this sort of way that we
Traverse conversation a dialectic and
dialogue between two people and you were
explaining how one person will be giving
this scenario then you're talking about
it again right now just painting this
world and then all of a sudden there
will be this crisis point and and that
and that could be the moment when the
other person says I agree with you on
that crisis point or I don't agree with
you because of this or you know
I'm gonna hit the tennis ball back with
a little bit of spin in the end of this
intellectual tennis ball and then you're
also describing something interesting
here is this painting the world so if I
mean if I'm painting you a world this is
a one that you know I'm recently it's
been kind of interested in is what does
the world look like once once it's
indistinguishable to tell between a
human and an artificial intelligence
completely at the bar at the Museum or
wherever you're walking around and once
it's indistinguishable at that point
then now the ideas when we paint a world
like that are we now the question is
what are we trying to say by that are we
trying to say that this is a important
foresight to have we should analyze this
and be weary of it and be ready for it
and explore what it looks like or are we
trying to say like oh my god this is
fearful this is a crisis point oh my
gosh
so you can be kind of painting this
world for people with an intention of
them maybe we're looking at ourselves in
the mirror in the present moment or
thinking about the future is it fear is
it is it happiness and right there this
is I think in the case of most science
fiction you utopian dystopian it has a
spin it has a very particular way in
which it's trying to make an argument
once again and this is certainly true of
fables when you think about Aesop's
fables for instance and so there's a
moral at the end he actually didn't
write those morals but nevertheless
that's how we receive them today and
that that has its role it as does
argument as does an impassioned position
which as long as that impassioned
position is not ultimately a prejudice
can in fact function within society at
large in a useful way in terms of
allowing for counter positions to build
upon and also getting us somewhere
ultimately we have to decide to do
something versus something else so
ultimately we need to make some sort of
a decision but what I'm interested in is
how do we have this experimental space
this possibility space
where it is not predetermined that this
is meant to comment one way or another
so I'm not interested in satire as far
as what I do I'm not interested in
parody I'm not interested in polemic
what any lemak I'm not interested in
making an argument Hellenic Lee speaking
making an argument for the sake of
proving a point proving a point or
persuading you is probably more what I'm
seeing so the experiments that you're
running are just foreplay to the point
of science or technology or inquiry in
just general well I think that they are
spaces in which play is a an important
aspect of it and some may be more
playful than others some may enter into
a space that I create and they might
then play within that space roleplay for
instance or otherwise try out different
possibilities within that space others
might simply come upon it through other
means through the media I always run a
media campaign around a project in order
to get it into as large a space of
discourse as possible which really I
think relates to what what you're up to
here is exactly how do we how do we get
ideas and thinking into as large a space
engaging as many people as possible and
that is where I think we have a mission
in common yes we do yes so should we put
bring up some of the ones that you've
done sure I so I think that that would
be a good way in which to make what
probably is completely confusing and
opaque in its own right perhaps a little
bit more grounded yes
and we have this insane amount of noise
now because there's so much data there's
so much information now it's hard to
parse for signal and we spend so much of
our time running around in the economic
and political machine it makes it
difficult to slow down find space and
time to just think absolutely and I
think that because it's
to slow down and just think that we
don't build the mechanisms that make the
time so at this stage in history in the
economic political system in which we
live it's almost a subversive act and
yeah it's almost I think a matter of
because there there are legitimate
reasons why most people cannot spend
their entire lifetime in thought or even
can spend days of the week doing what I
do i happen to have managed to find ways
in which to do it and to survive on that
basis it's rare and it's a privileged
position and I don't want to inflict
that privilege on others or to to
restrict those who participate in this
because you need a certain level of
privilege in what you do so so rather
what I'm trying to do is to say but you
live quite humbly in order to and yeah I
think that ability happened free but
even so humbly in a first-world kind of
way so I need to be honest with myself
but I believe that everybody can find
five minutes out of the day to get out
of whatever they need to do in order to
be able to survive yeah in order to
release to really live and to ultimately
contribute to that longer-term survival
that's only possible if we are engaged
in deep thought about who and what we
are what we want to become and how we
can do it collectively in a way that is
not going to be toxic to others well
what is that gonna do the to the rules
of the world that do not want us
thinking critically and taking time away
from this big picture of ours and saying
hey what's going on here this makes
absolutely no sense I have so much more
in my mind other than this elementary
systematic oppressive state that we live
in
and there's so much more to explore in
the human mind than that elementary
fundamental state that sometimes it
feels like we're prison didn't know [ __ ]
we're just prisoned in there sometimes
so ok so let's take this this idea of
experiments of philosophy and tinkering
and playing to play and playing to
explore and having enough time to do so
and let's see how we can form
large-scale events and large-scale
thought experiments and and and showcase
that play and inspire for an inspire
more we have to redesign the social
fabric a little bit to enable people to
take that five-minute break more often
you should we we don't have we don't
have to do that first I think that what
I do is highly deeply imperfect flawed
in any number of ways but I think at
least it does you can do something why
are you so hard on yourself
your what your work is fascinating and
it's it's because because it's a state
of humility to say that hey like I
understand by choice yourself some props
there but it is good exactly yeah okay
so I want to make sure that we get to
all the different things that we need to
talk about I'm one of them on the way to
you being able to do these experiments
is the fact that you don't have a cell
phone you have a landline and you have
email and and this is this is another
you're now the second person I know the
first person's Aubrey de Grey he chooses
to not have a cell phone because he
calls it the ultimate destroyer of human
solitude or personal solitude now will
you explain to us why you do choose to
not have a cell phone I think that is a
broader question of technology and my
relationship to it I'm not a pen I'm not
opposed to it I'm certainly not a
Luddite I'm also not a technophile I
don't wreck inherently because but first
of all everything is technology every
artifact certainly counts as technology
a hand axe is technology as much as a
cell phone and I can choose what I want
to use as a way in which to choose
how I want to live and who I want to be
and so a cellphone simply has never
seemed essential to me and then why well
I'm here and clearly I didn't die as a
result of not having a cell phone
clearly I didn't even feel the urge to
have a cell phone I think that there's a
way in which not having a cell phone at
least allows me to escape
allows me to do for myself what Aubrey
de Grey would argue everyone needs to do
and I would agree everybody needs that
whether they need to use those means and
whether vilifying one or another
technology is legitimate that that's
where I respectfully disagree with him I
don't think that a cell phone is evil
we do think that I don't need one and
that there are many other technologies
that we don't necessarily need I've
never owned a car either I don't need a
car you know that's not that's not what
we were thinking at 5:30 when we were
looking for you there Jonathan you know
I just want to say that you know I'm
sure so I don't think Aubrey either
vilifies it but in in this extent of
everybody 99.9 nnnn and and I'm percent
of humanity has a cell phone the love
the developed world let's say and then
zero points is there one percent of
people like you just chooses not to own
one and then there's this amazing area
in between which is I know how to put my
phone on silent and not look at it for
extensive periods of time so I can focus
so there is an airplane mode there's
these different kind of immediately and
actually I created a work for cell phone
I created a ringtone some years ago back
when custom ringtones were just becoming
popular it was it was silent so it was
four minutes and 33 seconds of silence
John Cage one of the great avant-garde
composers the 20th century composed a
work that changed everything in music
which was a work that was four minutes
and 33 seconds of silence that was
performed in all earnestness in a
concert hall on piano in the early
instantiations of it where the performer
did not play for those four minutes
and didn't even move their hands they
just sat there on the and just quiet for
four minutes 33 seconds again and just
stood up and bowed yes and you can do it
in any number of different ways but my
thought was that's analog I can do it
digitally I can make it even I can make
a better silence in a certain sense also
it's not portable
I mean grand piano not portable exactly
so a cell phone as a mechanism for
making silence is really interesting to
me because we live in a world that's so
noisy as you say so what happens if you
have on your body at all times silence
and that silence can manifest at any
time and you don't even know when it's
manifesting even on a crowded bus
somehow you can put something on that
Google could be reading no it isn't even
that it isn't even a matter of trying to
somehow shut yourself out it's a matter
of the fact that the silence is
happening in addition to whatever else
is happening and that that silence can
in fact not be happening because maybe
nobody's calling you but maybe you think
somebody's calling so maybe that it's a
phantom silence is even more of AIT's a
way in which to silence your mind in a
way in which to to get out of the noise
that is busyness that is running around
that is constantly being on other's
schedule exactly that is a very good
point it's that when somebody sends you
a message or sends you a call or sends
you an email it is not your
responsibility to be on their schedule
and pick up the call or answer the
message or answer the email and actually
it's more often better to turn off those
expressions those genetic expressions
let's call them and turn off that people
Network turn it off and very rarely
actually pick it up or respond because
there are again apply the Preta
principle only a certain amount and this
is this manifesto that I just released
today that that is exactly what we need
to start focusing on doing more okay
let's get to these points so we got one
of the thought experiments that you've
done is the travel documentary for
plants so yes so this is probably a good
way in which to illustrate and so yeah
what a thought experiment is
mm-hmm okay because it's it's a
relatively simple case so your projector
and some plants in this photo so I'm
just back up a little bit and say that
this is not where this project began
okay but rather the project began with
thinking about getting into filmmaking a
lot of people are already doing it
there's no sense in me trying to compete
with James Cameron so I thought to
myself well what audience might I reach
that was not being catered to by
Hollywood or any other producers out
there and I thought well you know
planets plants are actually an ideal
audience for film because film what is
it it's light so plants perform
photosynthesis so projecting light
directly onto their foliage would be a
way in which they would be able to
experience film perhaps to an even
greater extent than we can do so that
led me to think about what do you do
what kind of movies do you make and I
started out as many bill makers okay so
the idea is that if you project light
onto plants that they will absorb that
light yes at photosynthesize and that
that could that they could feel or enjoy
the light in different ways than we do
for Thea yes different ways but also
potentially in ways that are are not
different and that's where it gets
interesting so I started out in
pornography itself and we're filmmakers
get their start I did so by filming
honey bees pollinating flowers I project
that directly onto the foliage of the
plants allowed them vicariously to
experience the titillation of shadowplay
of honey bees hovering well that's not
really pornography though it's cuz it's
honey you're not a plan yeah plan says
pornography exactly yourself in the
position of a plant and partly I think
that's what I'm interested in is what
happens when we do that yeah so then I
decided to make travel documentaries
your plans to go to legit so how are you
I make a travel document her plan you're
probably not going to show they'll clamp
the Eiffel Tower not going to be that
interesting not going to show the Golden
Gate Bridge but foreign skies that could
be interesting so I film skies in Europe
and then projected them onto the foliage
of plants in New York and again I had to
think about how oh do I not have the
perm or Phi's how do I make
is true to the plants experience so the
first was shadowplay for that
pornography because that's really what's
happening you've got the Sun cloud plant
and you've got basically honeybees
hovering in the case of the sky
you have clouds but plants don't focus
the light they don't see clouds as forms
so that's why in this picture here you
can see a scrim a projector projecting
through a scrim illuminating the plants
with the aggregate light so this is yet
another sort of movie for a plants and
I've subsequently made a third that I
just released at a film festival at CERN
in Geneva and that was to make sci-fi
for plants so I took the spectral
signature of different stars and then
allowed plans to travel from Earth to
these 581d and to do so passing
different star systems along the way and
ultimately to go from a sunrise on earth
to a sunset simulated obviously if I
couldn't actually get to Gliese 581d
a simulated sunset on this exoplanet
that is largely believed yes right now
to be a place where life could subsist
yes they love exoplanet science and so
ok so you were trying to move plants to
exoplanets for them to feel like what
would it be like to absorb the other
star's light by Kary so yes interest and
so all of this I think become and you
expanded the awareness of people in
again in a new way you were like what
would it be like for a plant to be there
just like what it would be right human
to be there as well well and and even
more basically what is this thing that
we do when we go into a theater or we
watch television or we look at anything
on a screen how how are we processing
this into what extent are we even aware
of the fact that there are differences
not better or worse but differences
between mediated experience on a screen
and experience out in the world so a lot
of questions potentially get asked and
the idea is for me just as notice you
have a watch so you do keep track of
yeah I'm indeed and and many of my
projects actually are about time yeah so
I'm interested in this case and saying
what happens when we get outside of
ourselves I need to make the best movies
I can for plans I need to make the
absolute
rigorously I need to think through how
not to anthropomorphize those plans yes
in order for us then to encounter the
plants undergoing this experience it's
very familiar to us in a way that is be
familiarized and is absurd and that
absurdity is a space of disorientation
that potentially brings us back around
to asking ourselves about how we receive
and how we process reality our own input
exactly and our own sense our own
sensory systems and our own systems of
cognition I don't want to claim this
there's a whole field of plant
neurobiology which is somewhat a
misnomer and problematic for that but it
is in in fact the case that plants
somehow process their world they
wouldn't be here if they didn't so what
can we learn about this more general
state of processing the world and how
can that make us more aware of the ways
in which we're doing so that may be
different from the ways in which others
are doing so that may make us more aware
of others more of a theory of mind in
the broadest possible sense of the word
and also maybe more of a sense in which
we are able to find commonalities and in
a world that is increasingly toxic to
other species to other organisms which
is only you desperately need know so
this is just exactly so we need to strip
out all the color if you go on to
youtube actually you can find the
trailer for that piece it was it was so
if you look up plant pornography
probably isn't a whole lot there it was
I don't know 2006-2007 put my name in as
well I think you're going to find a
trailer for the original version of that
and yes said cinema Botanica that was
pornographer God that's a different
story
so if you go back I mean we can talk
about that as well but I'm sorry I mean
it did you know no this is this is
interesting what do you want me to do so
go back to the GU where you could select
and then click instead on the other
video that pornography I'm a Botanica
there you go
tell us a while ago these are embedding
a screen within a screen here so as you
can see basically what I've done is I
thought through how do I make it so that
the porn is as true to a plant's eye
view of the world and then to ask to
what extent is that experience
meaningful to the plan as a way of
asking where we derive meaning in our
own lives but also as a way of trying to
ask what we have in common what
differences we have and how we navigate
that how do we relate to other species
in ways other than how we are doing so
right now which is largely by bulldozing
and by ignoring at best but generally
speaking by dominating the planet in a
way that is ultimately unsustainable to
earth other species and also to us
exactly it's existential risk now more
than ever is how we treat it along the
way ok so let's take just one thing that
you said from this and then kind of go
on to the next one is just that this
notion of the unfamiliarity we have the
familiarity of all the sensory inputs
all the cognition that we receive on a
daily basis and you enjoy really
flipping it on its head or showing it in
an unfamiliar way like what would it be
like to be a plant on another planet
absorbing light from That star what
would it be like for us to be on that
planet absorbing light from a different
star or even some things but now as as
the sky it doesn't need to be what would
it be like to have the sky in Australia
right now instead of the United States
sky and and again you're just putting
ourselves in unfamiliar places why is
that interesting why is it interesting
to to go into airplane mode for on your
phone for long periods of time what
would it be like to do that same thing
with our 10-day meditation retreats that
we've been on we don't use cell phones
we don't use technology no eye contact
no speaking for 10 straight days and
when you do that in you tune in word for
10 days and so you're flipping society
on its head because you're going away
from well the sensory inputs all away
from the cognition and in order when you
win one does that it's a profound shift
in the way that we experience life and
so it's anything to get with you it's
not junket whatever it's also what you
care
as a result of having been there having
done that exactly and then so the next
one is this quantum wedding sweet indeed
so I was thinking about marriage and how
it is kind of weird how some sort of
authority political authority or
religious authority gets to say what
sort of relationship you are permitted
to have with others or with another
actually as hold on I drew with you so
my thought was what if instead of basing
it on some law of the land we were to
think about marriage in terms of some
law that was more universal law of
nature or the law of maybe what two
people would want well they can draft
their own yeah like a five year plan
you know after five years you can either
renegotiate or give her the boot yeah
and we have friends that do that they
negotiate like monthly plans a monthly
that'd be fantastic yeah it's just
interesting some people want full life
some people might want only a couple
year tech it but we need to get there or
one night and in order to get there I
think we need to get out of the
assumptions and the ways in which
relationships are made legitimate
through systems that are not flexible
and systems that are dogma legitimate in
their own right perhaps so my thought
was okay law of nature
well quantum entanglement is a
fascinating phenomenon that actually
works very well in terms of what it what
does it mean to be together well I can't
think of any more married state than the
state that two particles are in when
they're in a state of entanglement where
anything that happens to one of them
instantaneously also happens to the
other effectively so my thought was how
could I bring that into Las Vegas
because Las Vegas is where you people
get married so I I opened a quantum
wedding suite in Las Vegas in an old
abandoned motel and it was a place where
and again it's all about rigor at the
outset and absurdity that results when
rigor is applied in ways that then allow
for anything to happen so you're looking
here at a nonlinear crystal which is the
means by which you entangle photons when
you're running a lab experiment and this
apparatus also uses a beam splitter and
by these means allows for two streams of
entangled photons to bombard people who
are standing in front of the apparatus
and that number can be any number that
you like it can be entanglement in any
way that you choose but ultimately was
happening is by way the photoelectric
effect that electrons are being
entangled some part of you for some
period of time and it may be one
electron and maybe for less than a
nanosecond is most likely getting
entangled with another or with others
and you can define those terms in in
terms of who you bring into the room
what you do there any way that you like
but but it allows for a relationship
that is not based on anybody saying this
is how it goes and I confer this upon
you it's something that you can
undertake and the thing about it is in
the case of any quantum system if you
measure it it collapses if you measure
an entangled state it becomes this
entangled and I think that that's also
an interesting way in which to be
married ultimately is to be in a state
where you're not measuring or
questioning that state of togetherness
and that when you actually go about that
measurement if you doubt that you are
entangled and you make the measurement
to find out whether you are become
disentangled it isn't to say that that's
how it needs to be but it is when you
take this thought experiment you're on
15-minute timer okay
it's where are you we're at 43 I would I
would spend so anytime we will have a
two-hour episode I know we'll have
Jonathan come back for a part two of the
time today today I mean
talking for like three hours you got it
you've got to go to Star Wars Ronny so
yeah but I wanted I really want to um
this is this is so fascinating Jonathan
you're really a beautiful person I'm
just a little rough around the edges on
the show you know I'm playing the
devil's advocate but I think was
fantastic yeah well he's very he's
poking apart marriage he's showcasing
marriage from a new perspective flipped
on its head in different ways that is
non-conventional
we love this type of stuff so we'll have
to absolutely revisit another episode
where we dive deeper into all of this
but for now let's continue exploring
what is this importance of continuing to
poke at things in different ways here we
have the intergalactic Omni phonics
all right so orchestrating live music
for for life throughout the universe
okay so you you are playing live music
to other places in the universe not
exactly
I actually just about it trying to
create the context in which you can
perform music with any being anywhere in
the universe without any of the
assumptions or prejudices that are built
into our own instruments which is to say
the ways in which we assume that all
others are like us in terms of their
sensory systems in terms of their
cognitive systems what what it would
mean to set aside all those assumptions
and that becomes a basis for this much
larger attempt on my part a longer term
project of trying to foment a Copernican
revolution in the arts as a way of doing
so in culture more generally so I'll
come back around to this in a moment but
just to say in terms of the very big
picture I'm interested in how there was
a Copernican revolution in the sciences
500 years completely changed yes
everything not just making for easier
navigation not just in terms of
astronomy within our solar system
but the mediocrity principle basically
that we are no place special in place or
in time yes wealth is not the center of
the universe so my thought is that
happened in the sciences but it never
went beyond the sciences and we are in
our present society fundamentally
Ptolemaic that what is all-american so
the Ptolemaic system is as a term that's
typically used for the geocentric system
the system that that came before it
refers to Claudius Ptolemy who was an
astronomer who didn't come up with it
but just kind of he was one of the
people who elaborated on it and it gets
his name and so he gets vilified by all
the Copernicus so we treat as though
almost every system political economic
astronomic microscopic all these
different systems are somehow we these
are just in we're a little thing we're
at the middle it's all about it's all
about it's it's sort of concentric
circles around myself maybe my family
around my family
maybe my tribe whatever that is my
country my planet so it's his way in wit
yes rather than a Copernican worldview
which does not privilege me and does not
privilege by nation we are in a
xenophobic state of tribalism yeah a
state of being absolutely focused from
the inside out and what I want to do is
I want to bring about that Copernican
shift in society in general yes and I
think that we're worth you do so
potentially through the arts and through
music in particular because it's popular
because yes it is this is a way in which
what science could not achieve might
through popular culture infiltrate our
society and there might be some sort of
a fundamental shift as a result of that
so yes I'm trying to do this very
broadly by saying okay what if we get
Copernican about music that is to say
what if we make music truly universal
that is to say no assumptions whatsoever
about anything particular to me or to us
in the room or to us in this country or
to us on this planet so sensory systems
well in the first place there's no
reason to believe that the part of the
sound spectrum that we hear 20 to 20,000
Hertz is what any being anywhere in the
universe would hear back dogs don't hear
in the same way that we do they hear up
to 40,000 or so already we know right
here and now that it's much broader than
that
so sound however might not be accessible
to other beings there's no reason to
believe that every being has ears every
being throughout the universe yes so
what offenses have developed in
different ways in different places yeah
so you can make music in many other ways
potentially music effectors noise yeah
well I would say just as an even simpler
way of thinking about this the
constituent parts of music are frequency
in amplitude over time so any system
that has frequency and amplitude and
time allows for musical ideas to be
expressed in ways that are equivalent to
the music that we express using this 20
to 20,000 Hertz range of sound pressure
so that means visible light is visible
to us but it also means infrared
ultraviolet radio waves it means gamma
ray so I've built cells that are gamma
ray bells that use Radio isotopes and
the different Radio isotopes have
different spectral signatures have
different weakly and sense those we
cannot directly sense them and then so
it's happening and we don't we only know
what's happening because you have
started it but that we don't we can't
feel it or see it or taste it or smell
right and so I mean I start out actually
in much simpler terms I've built an
organ that is ultrasonic I went onto
eBay about dog whistles and I turned
them into an organ that is above our
hearing range the the gamma-ray bells
use these different Radio isotopes I've
also gone to an even greater extreme or
arguably with gravitational waves I get
it now intergalactic gamma phonics
so I created so gravitational children
so for other places
in the universe that have different
perceptions abilities that are not that
are very different than what we feel and
see and touch taste and smell you are
playing music for them with them yeah so
the idea is I think realistic how do we
have we have some interesting people to
introduce you to how do you have a
dialogue how do we have conversation how
do we have contact in ways that are not
privileged
that are not based on assumptions about
us and this is something that when you
go all the way out there if you can if
you can do that so if you can perform
using in an in an orchestra that has
instruments that are not only audible to
us but also that are that are actuated
gravitational waves then that's people
think about that it's cool how it is
really and we have the gravitational
cello actually is one of our images
Ronnie can you throw up the
gravitational cello image that would be
fantastic right now that is cool that
then allows for us to it's it becomes
the aliens and our myths how does our
order how it makes it so that it's that
much more trivial to imagine having
interaction with them and I think that
music as a mode of interaction because
it can be a jam session it can be a sort
of a spontaneous yes way in which to
interact with each other it could be a
very effective way in which to have that
sort of open-ended dialogue and so yeah
and when you have this whole gamut of
instruments many of which are not
immediately accessible to us it then
opens up this possibility space where
all bets are off where anything can
happen and also where we recognize that
we may not know at all we may not sense
at all that that there might be other
modality so there's a certain humility
that gets built in I think which is the
opposite of the hubris the xenophobia in
our society but it's also the
inclusiveness a radical inclusiveness
that happens when you have this
orchestra which initially manifested at
the University North Carolina and
Asheville where I spent a semester as a
Black Mountain College legacy fellow and
then which I brought to Ser
sisqó with intergalactic Amna ponics
manufacturing instruments such as the
gravitational cello yeah to answer your
question how does it work so very simply
gravitational waves we've only just now
detected them and what detectives as the
Earth orbits around the star it ripple
ripple effect occurs through space-time
so other every plan it's cascading this
gravitational wave
sensing this so what we detected was
initially was two orbiting black holes
orbiting each other and that was
actually sending ripples through
space-time itself so that was not an
instrument that I know how to build I
don't have access back home black hole
technology exactly but as it turns out
absolutely any mass whatsoever yes will
actually will send gravitational waves
out very for all one in proportion to
the mass so therefore I can go get a
ball bearing which is what I've done if
you go back a few slides there go back
to the what I've done I've gotten a one
more I've gotten a some ball bearings of
different masses that allow you to
actuate at different amplitudes and then
frequency maps on to two accelerations
oh wait this oh there's this you could
attach one or another so the channel is
it's on a stand and then it when you
spin it you take it off the stand and
you move it and by moving it or your
nasally yourself right and by moving it
you're able to change your acceleration
because rotation is constant
acceleration so by rotating this mass at
different rates
you have control over frequency by
switching one mass for another you have
control over amplitude you're doing this
over time so you have all of the
constituent parts of musicality
but for gravitational weights which are
not accessible to us in the first place
and certainly not at this level but
what's to say for another being
elsewhere in the universe and so then
this then becomes a platform for saying
okay what happens now when we have all
these instruments
what kind of music might we wait well
and if your ear is positioned right next
to one point at least along it you can
maybe hear it kind of eyes you probably
end up with a concussion yeah I don't
want to be liable so but so what
musical instruments can we make what
Omni phonics can we make for the galaxy
for the universe right how can we expand
like you said the Copernican revolution
of this of understanding that we are not
at the center of everything that we
think about and do to deteriorate this
identity is immense we don't know it all
we don't experience at all yes and we
can be aware of what we don't experience
and what we can't experience even and
that can open us up and that we can
actually interact by those means as well
as it means that we can experience yeah
and that can be a way in which to have a
more open sort of dialog with fewer
assumptions built into it and then you
can start making different kinds of
music around that we can start thinking
about how do we how do we then get rid
of a cognitive assumptions how do we get
rid of experiential zombies what sort of
music do we make what sort of
foundations might we use to build some
sort of a conversation that is genuinely
inclusive yes I love it okay and then a
deep time photography let's touch on
this so you're taking photographs over
centuries and millenniums yes so and
generally speaking my own monologues go
over centuries and millennia so I think
that I'm sure we're gonna run out of
time here on this but I will just say
relatively quickly and you take your
time on woke the show and just just stop
the stream when you're done all right
I'll do it all right Jonathan great to
meet you thank you so much are you
staying on the center cam the rest of
the time yeah all right somebody's machi
from this man as you can all right that
sounds good all right number let's hang
out let's go to Santa Cruz and noise
prison beautiful I got I have a sense of
time now on I'll flip the phone up so I
can see the time Ron have a good time at
Star Wars
we'll hit these last two points talk a
little bit more and then we'll also send
Jonathan off well we'll be hanging more
soon all right okay so I'm back to you
also are on a timer at 6:52 so let's
just talk through deep time photography
and we can lead future projects for the
future yes
that sounds great okay so in the
centuries of the bristlecones
so that's the future so okay so we'll
leave yes well we'll leave the project
that's with a long now foundation then
about a museum of art which is a fight
that was in a year-long project so it
makes my Millennium camera seem like
pocket change but we have thrown as
though is the longest living species on
the planet as far as we know Wow so but
it aren't like sharks and ocean
creatures are older reptilians well
individual sharks are not living on the
order as far as not one as live 5000
exactly but you know that one tree
species yeah yeah well and I'm not
speaking of it as an area would be the
species or as a species so it's arguable
what's the last Universal common
ancestor
cyanobacteria has been proposed
potentially as being very early on as
far as extant species but no I think he
was single right yeah so this is that's
a good teaser we're going to turn that
into a time keeping mechanism that's
going to ground time in the world as we
live it but right now what you're
looking at is a camera so this is a
project that I started some years ago in
Berlin thinking about how every time
that I went to Berlin everything changed
gentrification was overtaking the city
but people who lived there were not
really able to see that because it was
in a constant way that complacency
allows for a lot to happen and so I
thought what mechanism might I be able
to use you know be able to like for
example I showed this photo of London
from like 1916 to my social network yes
and it was a very interesting talking
point because it was like look at what
people were wearing look at how many
people look at what the advertisements
were like what the buildings were like
look at what the transit was like yes
and so these were all completely
different than so if you can look if you
like for example we could take a
snapshot of Singapore from ten years ago
and then a snapshot of Singapore from
five years
go and just look at these of the same
sphere or maybe the same street view or
the same top-down view it would change
drastically but if you live there you
might not notice it so much and there's
been a lot of Rifa tog Rafi which is
very interesting in its own right in
terms of looking both at cities and at
natural environments that's actually not
at all what I'm doing though I'm very
interested in it
what I was thinking was what might be a
way in which to make people more aware
of what I refer to as deep time
borrowing a term from geology what what
might happen if there were some means by
which we were being watched by the
future so in in the case of the city and
here's at Berlin and subsequently other
cities my thought was what if I were to
make a surveillance camera
that wasn't the state watching you or
your neighbor but was in fact those who
are most affected by the decisions that
we make but at least empowered to have
any way in which to shape those
decisions the decisions that ultimately
will make the world that they're born
into the way that it is that is to say
those yet bore so the idea was make a
camera with a hundred year long exposure
and then have a lot of them distributed
through the city watching over whatever
happens over that period of time and
then in a hundred years
have an exhibition in which you're able
to see not before and after or not
moment by moment in terms of segments in
time but the whole change though the all
of time compressed into a single image
so a movie compressed into a single
image so the idea is basically pinhole
camera a camera that lets in very little
light focusing the light through a
pinhole projecting it not onto ordinary
film which wouldn't go for more than a
few years is really the maximum there
but rather onto ordinary black paper
that will fade in sunlight you have a
magazine on your coffee table and it
will fade in time same idea here but
you're projecting light in a focused way
what happens I'll take about a
basketball game where you see
the player as kind of a ghost against a
backdrop where you see the basket
perfectly clearly so in a sense what
you're seeing is something that is
transient something that is not and
you're able to unpack that picture there
might be an equivalent sort of case in a
photograph over a hundred years where a
lot of change is going to be seen in
ghostly terms whereas those things that
remain constant will actually be quite
hard on the exact plate so it becomes
possible to see change we've seen this
in the long exposure photography right
well taking photos of maybe the stars
yes and then somebody walks by and they
look like a ghost
so and you have the phenomenon of the
double of a double negative as well
where you take a snapshot in another one
all on the same piece of film and so
there might be an equivalent there where
a house gets torn down after 20 years
and a big building goes up in its place
you would have the shadow of a house the
ghost of the house and the building that
much more strongly in the image so
therefore you really are allowing the
future at least potentially to look at
the whole period of time and the cameras
are out there in a way that well the
surveillance cameras so I hope they make
us a little bit paranoid and they're
hidden so you don't know when you're
being watched most of these of course
are gonna fail if it's not all of them I
started out with a hundred of them and
they were given to people to be able to
distribute throughout the city and to
tell a child when they get to be very
old or to leave the information in their
will so that it gets passed on exactly
so it becomes a means by which the next
generation then is able to retrieve the
cameras and to see to see the decisions
that we made but it also becomes a way
in which we are able to look at our
decisions from their vantage potentially
yes it's so it's a camera that's looking
through time in both directions it's
what everything documentary photography
is not meant to be documentary
photography is not supposed to interfere
this is interfering this is a case in
which you're being watched and you can
change the picture you can make
decisions based on the longer term based
on this whole scope of a hundred
and it becomes a way in which to see
yourself from a definite point in the
future which is to say not to have that
blur that is what leads to the
complacency that Maine makes for
gentrification without thinking it
through and also you have the the
ability to be in a sort of a dialogue
with the far future so this is something
that in an urban setting can really
speak to how you go about making a city
of the future or making your city over
time for the future but there's also an
even longer term prospect that is
possibly even more important that is to
say how we interact with the environment
the fact is that we are now capable of
changing everything on a scale of a
thousand ten thousand a hundred thousand
years in a moment's time we did not
evolve that way we did we evolved with
the hand acts as our premiere technology
where you could change the immediate
environment around you over a period of
perhaps years now it is on a scale that
we just don't have the means by which to
understand what we're doing we don't
have the means to be able to use our
power responsibly and we've shown that
we're incredibly irresponsible with it
so what might be a sort of a
technological prosthesis a means by
which to be able to start to think in
the sort of deep time that we operate in
so I decided to build a camera with a
that was in two-year long exposure in
that case it becomes a more challenging
prospect and 100-year camera you can use
ordinary paper paper last for a hundred
years I can use cheap materials and make
them widely available in fact I've I've
made a version that's made out of
cardboard you basically cut it out make
it into a cardboard box poke a hole in
it and most of them won't survive but
the few that do might just be a means by
which to see in the future what happened
over time and it remains even if that
doesn't happen a prompt that we can work
on that we can act on the fact that
there might be a camera watching the
thousand-year camera uses 24 karat gold
as the material through which the
aperture
been punctured and instead of paper uses
a renaissance oil painting technique
with a paint that we know is fugitive in
terms of its color but where we know
that it's stable in terms of the fact
that it will survive on the back of this
camera made out of copper so everything
is in archaeological terms and an art
art historical or conservation our
conservation terms as validated as can
be well I don't know what will happen I
can at least say that I have data as a
basis for doing this as rigorously as
possible to put these cameras out there
and so far there are two of them one
looking out at the City of Tempe from
Arizona State University the second one
at Amherst College looking out at the
Holyoke range so an urban environment
over deep time Huell and a so-called
natural environment and it's about to
get much bigger and more distributed
with four of them that are about to go
up in lake tahoe looking at the lake
from four different Vantage's good and
we'll take it from there I'm trying to
figure out how to make this into a
project for UNESCO where World Heritage
Sites have these cameras and also where
the simple version of the camera the
cardboard cutout camera is something
that potentially every child gets as a
birthright and potentially becomes this
iterative ongoing process its way in
which were relating through time with
future generations yes there are
sentinels that are looking out through
time and they were able to see ourselves
from the far future and to then make
decisions in a way that are embedded in
deep time our minds become embedded in
deep time while at the same time
participating in some sort of deep time
by way of this shorter span that isn't
just over the verge of what a generation
survives to be and of course aubrey de
grey is going to tell you otherwise and
maybe it will be but then we'll just
make it a 200-year camera we can keep
upping the gamut in order to keep that
dynamic in play so that's deep time
photography it's a thought experiment as
well and some of the thought experiments
I think potentially they're funny
I mean pornography for plants is
probably people laugh and I think that's
a great thing because when you laugh
you're off guard and you potentially
have a sort of conversation
yeah I think you might not otherwise
other projects like the deep time
photography project are certainly there
is some sort of an absurdity inherent in
building cameras and absurd sort of hope
perhaps and but certainly there there's
a realm of disorientation that subsists
in the absurd that is means by which to
then reorient that is I think inherent
in all of these projects and that makes
it so that every one of these projects
is this sort of a thought experiment
that is happening in the here and now
but also is a means by which to project
ourselves forward to explore possible
worlds and then to make our future more
informed collectively individually in
terms of the experiences that we've had
in some sort of a system a systematic
play that then makes it so that the
future that we actually build is perhaps
a future that is better for us and would
be the case if we simply were to be
complacent careless or simply give it
over to the political systems that don't
seem to be working in our best interest
Jonathan I'm so grateful to have all
this conversation and likewise in the
way that you describe the importance of
deep time photography I think is it kind
of treats it gets us closer to seeing
ourselves in the mirror and I we talk
about the importance of that so much on
the show this is a very very long-term
mirror it had for all its has to be a
long-term mirror for society has to be
that way and there's this long term
mirror that we hold in front of
ourselves and that's kind of this be
better than you were yesterday and also
future authoring look at what you want
to be in a year five years ten years how
do you get there and then there's this
societal mirror and that like if there's
a mirror right by the International
Space Station or even further out and we
just get to look at it and we're like
dad
like objectively there are just some
things on the planet that we can make
better over time the mirrors on the moon
the mirrors of our mind that's a good
one bounce yeah yeah actly
exactly so in order to be able to
actually see ourselves in the mirror
objectively overtime and like you said
there is this way of doing things like
these deep times that took photographs
that can that can that can more easily
communicate this thought experiment to
next generations and for them onward and
I'm really happy that you're working
with long now there are definitely some
people that came to mind that we'll be
introducing you to that can hopefully
accelerate some of this impact into our
world we'll definitely be doing a part
two excellent and that were to it I look
forward to it as well so maybe we can
even do a live event together that would
be a lot of fun as well sure I can do a
thought experiment and we can exactly
that's why I was mentioning the I want
to pull a freaking confetti shooter out
and and then I want to throw a beach
ball out you know these these are the
little thought experiments these are
very small ones and mm-hmm
one can even do it whatever just start
with a a 30-minute pinhole camera right
you can start with these small ones and
experiencial play experimental
philosophy these are really great ways
to make ourselves better and understand
time more and understand play more
understand the senses that we don't have
the perception that we don't have the
cognition that we don't have I really
love thinking about what senses and
cognition has involved evolved on other
planets orbiting stars well make some
instruments do it all yourself I'm
simply doing it because no one else is
and I'm not any better than anyone else
I'm probably worse than most at most
everything that I do but you got to get
started and ideally it then brings
others into this business of doing
experimental philosophy so I very much
hope that happens and let's keep the
conversation going
yes you have opened that door and I
think other people are following through
and we've opened the door in many ways
and we are exactly like you we have so
many things that go wrong that other
people do so much better than us but we
hope
- you know open the door for the
big-scale sports stadiums filling those
up with curious intellectuals and also
for creative incubators because how many
beautiful ideas are there that don't get
talked about or don't get brought into
the world because we were fearful or we
don't take the risk and so many reasons
why people don't have the resources
they're starving for electricity or food
or water so they have to focus on that
first Jonathan what a freaking pleasure
likewise thank you so much for coming
onto the show absolutely pick it up
again we'll pick it up again soon thanks
everybody for tuning in if you guys had
a good time go and talk about
experiential philosophy with other
people go and start new thought
experiments yourself that is so
important go and create and document
yourself creating it and then go write
about it or make a video about it go and
create don't just consume at this
content also comment below with your
thoughts subscribe join family during
the community let's go and start talking
about these things more join us on
patreon we're trying to sustain this
build it increase it its impact so join
us there thanks everybody for tuning in
much love and we'll see you soon thank
you